Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, ich glaube, ich habe mir einen Hacker eingetreten.
Schick doch einfach eine E-Mail zurück und schalt den Server ab.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 493 vom 17. Mai 2024.
Und ich zittere, ich habe Angst.
Wovor?
Vom Hacker.
Vom Hacker? Ja. Nee, brauchst du nicht, machst du Hackpack. Hackpack?
Einfach mit einer E-Mail den Server ausschalten, ja das wäre doch mal sinnvoll.
Das wäre eine super Technologie, aber existiert diese Technologie bereits?
Das weiß man nicht. Ich meine, der Gerhard Schindler, Ex-Präsident des BND,
vielleicht sitzt der da auch einfach auf einem echt fetten Exploit.
Wollen wir da mal kurz reinhören?
Es ist immer wieder interessant zu sehen, was die Geheimdienste,
die kommen an Informationen, da haben wir einfach keine Ahnung von.
Hören wir mal exklusiv rein.
Einmal aber nur Wer hätte gedacht, dass das so einfach ist Verstehst du Wozu
gibt es überhaupt diese ganze Security Szene Diese ganzen Berater,
Wenn man auch, man hätte einfach Eine Mail schicken können Ja.
Einfach mal eine Mail zurückschicken Du.
Kannst jetzt eigentlich umschulen Auf Gartenbau Weil dein Job ist jetzt gemacht Mein.
Job ist gemacht.
Einfach eine E-Mail schicken Faszinierend übrigens.
Also Gerhard Schindler war Präsident des Bundesnachrichtendienstes bis 2016
und ist seitdem Lobbyist und Unternehmensberater mit dem Jobtitel Präsident
des Bundesnachrichtendienstes AD.
Da steht sowohl auf seiner Visitenkarte als auch auf seiner Online-Visitenkarte,
also da steht jetzt inzwischen noch Seniorberater, aber das kann ich sagen,
steht auf seiner Visitenkarte so nicht.
Zumindest nicht auf der, die ich habe.
Tja, wer will nicht solche Seniorberater haben? ich glaube, er ist eigentlich
Senior Consultant, aber Senior Berater habe ich glaube, das ist schon ganz gut getroffen.
Senioren Berater.
Senior Berater.
Hast du schon gewählt, Tim?
Ich? Gewählt? Im Kopf? Oder in Zilber? Bar.
Beides.
Ich habe meine Wahl-Benachrichtigungen hier liegen.
Du hast einen QR-Code drauf, dann kriegst du noch einen Brief.
Genau, dann kriege ich noch einen Brief und dann könnte ich...
Per Briefwahl wählen. Mache ich vielleicht auch noch mal gucken,
aber ich bin definitiv am 9.
Juni 2024, ein Sonntag, ohnehin in Berlin, das ist sicher.
Und von daher könnte ich es halt auch selber wahrnehmen und diesen schönen Modus beschreiten.
Ja.
Worum geht's? Es geht um die Europawahl 2024.
Eine Wahl, die gemeinhin als nicht ganz so wichtig angesehen wird in der Bevölkerung,
nicht nur in der deutschen Bevölkerung, generell in Europa, glaube ich.
Also es mag Ausnahmen geben, es mag Länder geben, die das ein bisschen ernster
nehmen als Deutschland.
Es mag auch Länder geben, die es noch weniger ernst nehmen als Deutschland.
Aber wir sind der Meinung, und deswegen erwähnen wir das jetzt auch,
Auch, dass das ganz wichtig ist.
Das gilt generell eigentlich für jede Wahl, aber es gilt immer besonders für
die nächste Wahl, weil es immer wichtiger wird.
Und auch wenn wir so ein bisschen das Gefühl haben, dass wir hier zu den Konvertierten
predigen, in der Hinsicht, kann man sich ja nicht so sicher sein.
Ja, vor allem wollen wir keine, also die Teilnahme daran ist für all jene streng
nahegelegt, die nicht möchten, dass eine,
also was ist das denn?
Also Vaterlands verratende Nationalisten? Oder was haben wir da gerade?
Achso, du meinst diese Russian Tools, die wir da jetzt im Parlament eingetreten haben?
Ja, also deren Vorstellung von Patriotismus ist auf jeden Fall sehr,
wie soll ich sagen, offenbar sehr dehnbar.
Es ist einfach eine Bande von mafiösen Idioten.
Achso, und hier der Björn Höcke wurde ja jetzt zu 100 Tagessätzen verurteilt.
Ich glaube, das ist noch nicht rechtskräftig.
Aber wenn, dann kann man ihn vorbestraften Faschisten nennen.
Weil er ist dann vorbestraft wegen der 100 Tagessätze. und dass man ihn Faschist
nennen darf, ist ja auch schon gerichtlich geklärt.
Bevor man das dürfte, müsste das Urteil aber noch rechtskräftig werden.
Da gibt es, glaube ich, noch irgendwie...
Da verschieben wir das noch. Aber falls ihr es nicht mitbekommen habt,
um beim Thema zu bleiben.
Also wir haben da eine AfD-Fraktion im Bundestag und aber auch schon das,
was in der europäischen Fraktion auch rumsitzt.
Das sind alles so Leute, die jetzt nachweislich, nachweislich ist jetzt ein
schwieriges Wort, weil das ist ja alles gerade im Laufe der Ermittlungen,
aber wo es schwer den Eindruck macht, dass die Leute halt unmittelbare Zahlungen
aus russischen Kreisen erhalten haben.
Und ich meine, man muss sich ja nicht lange damit beschäftigen,
um zu bemerken, wo die AfD so steht.
Da ist auch die AfD nicht alleine in der Parteienlandschaft,
es gibt da noch so ein paar andere, die das so mit der Vaterlandsliebe eher östlich ansiedeln.
AfD ist natürlich das spezifische Problem, beziehungsweise ist es generell das
Problem, dass wir eben ein Parlament erhalten könnten, was einfach noch weiter
nach rechts neigt, als das ohnehin schon der Fall ist.
Und europäische Politik ist wichtig, das merkt ihr ja auch, wenn man uns hier
zuhört, wie viele Entscheidungen im europäischen Parlament,
beziehungsweise vor allem in der Kommission, aber letzten Endes ist das ja so
ein Gesamtprozess, also Entscheidungen in Europa für Europa,
was das für einen Einfluss hat.
Nicht nur auf Netzpolitik, sondern natürlich Politik im Allgemeinen und ich
denke, dass die aktuelle Krisensituation noch sehr viel mehr dazu führen wird,
dass Europa da vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer zusammenrückt,
aber noch mehr zueinander finden muss,
um einfach die globalen Probleme und vor allem die Probleme,
die wir irgendwie mit Parteien außerhalb Europas so haben, um die noch irgendwie stemmen zu können.
Also Krieg in der Ukraine zum Beispiel, aber nicht nur das, Auseinandersetzung mit China etc.
Pp. Und da ist halt einfach nicht gut, wenn wir den Mafia-Anteil dann noch erhöhen
und das kann man eben dadurch absenken, Indem man einfach halbwegs vertrauenswürdige,
vielleicht sicherlich in ihrem
Treiben auch nicht unbedingt kritiklose Leute da noch mit dazu packen.
Man könnte auch einfach kurz sagen, man möchte vielleicht grundsätzlich nicht
und in dieser Situation auch nicht Faschisten wählen.
Zumal dann eben auch wirklich der Vollidioten-Anteil bei denen nochmal deutlich
höher ist als bei den anderen Parteien.
Enorm hoch, ja. Also wenn man sagt, vielleicht wähle ich mal Faschisten,
dann ist immer noch kein Grund Idioten zu wählen.
Also wenn Faschisten, dann bitte wenigstens ein paar Kompetente,
wenngleich sie ungleich schwerer zu finden sind.
Also bitte nicht AfD wählen und ihr könnt euch da, wir haben ja unsere Möglichkeiten
hier auch genutzt mit zwei Spezials, die wir hier mal so mit reingestreut haben
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten.
Einmal die LMP 477 mit dem Zentrum für politische Schönheit.
Die Anwälte sind die wahren Künstler.
Und in dichter Folge die LMP 482 mit Jean-Peters von Korrektiv.
Hört euch die nochmal an, bevor ihr irgendwo in der Nähe ein Kreuz macht.
Bonuspunkte gibt es, wenn nicht nur ihr wählen geht, sondern auch andere motiviert es zu tun.
Nehmt sie mit, bietet ihnen ein Sekt an oder sowas, was auch immer notwendig
ist, um eure euren Umgang da am Sonntag dem 9. Juni vor die Tür zu kriegen.
Genau. Und wenn die fragen, warum sie das tun sollten, sagt er,
Tim und Linus haben das gesagt.
Tim und Linus haben das gesagt und sie kriegen Sekt. Oder was auch immer für ein Getränk. Von euch.
So, dann 31.
August wollte ich nochmal kurz erwähnen.
Manifestiert sich langsam. Du hast jetzt irgendwo so ein, der Tim muss das immer
alles auf Papier machen.
Der wendet sich gegen den Digitalzwang.
Das ist schlimm.
In einer...
Das ist schlimm. Das muss wirklich mal thematisiert werden. Ich glaube,
ich muss dazu mal eine Online-Konferenz einberufen.
Genau. Ja, genau. Also genau, 31. August, Berlin, soll schönes Wetter geben, habe ich mir überlegt.
Und das so viel wäre es dann zum Prolog. Kommen wir zum Feedback, oder?
Gerne.
Also wir hatten ja in der letzten Folge den Kantorkel mit dem Thema Fake Shops.
Ich versuche gerade, ich bin gerade auf der Suche nach einer neuen Tasche.
Ich kaufe gerade Taschen.
Gucci?
Dolce & Gabbana habe ich mir. Das ist einfach mehr prolliger.
Louis Futon. Die sind so hässlich braun.
Also da verstehe ich überhaupt nicht. Genau, ich versuche gerade Taschen zu kaufen.
Und da wird dann auch häufig, lende ich dann dabei irgendwelchen komischen Shops und so.
Da bin ich gerade, denke ich auch immer so, boah Linus, Vorsicht,
ey, dann zitter ich auch.
Und denkst du, wenn du jetzt jetzt nach der Nummer auf so einen Fake-Shop reinfällst,
das darf jetzt einfach nicht mehr passieren.
Thomas kommentierte dazu, sehr spannend und vor allem schön.
So fängt ein guter Kommentar an, dass man sich darauf verlassen kann,
zu allen größeren Datengeschichten die Hintergrundinfos direkt in LNB auf die
Ohren zu bekommen. Richtig.
Die Frage, wer überhaupt ein Interesse an Aufklärung hat, musste ich mir neulich
auch stellen, als mir so 150 Euro durch ein Expedia-Phishing abhandengekommen sind.
Die Expedia dann aber schnell erstattet hat.
Das Interessante daran war, dass Expedia mich überzeugt hat,
auf das Phishing hereinzufallen, nachdem ich sie eigentlich auf ihr Sicherheitsproblem
hinweisen wollte. Lange Geschichte.
Am Ende wurde mir mein Geld und etwas Entschädigung erstattet und niemand will darüber reden. denn?
25.000 Webshops sind natürlich interessant, aber die gleiche Größenordnung,
in die gleiche Größenordnung kommt man vielleicht, wenn man irgendwie alle Hotels
angreifen könnte, die auf Booking, Expedia inserieren und vielleicht die gleiche
Software benutzen, um das abzuwickeln.
Wenn die eine Schwachstelle hat, die es erlaubt, den Kunden Nachrichten zu schicken,
kann man das gut skalieren und so viele kleinere Beträge ansammeln.
Okay, das war's jetzt mal.
Der entscheidende Punkt ist, zu dem Thema die Bank erstattet das dann schnell
und unkompliziert noch der freundliche Kommentar, dass diese Visa-Debit-Karten
auch deshalb bei Banken so populär sind,
weil da weniger versichert und erstattet wird.
In meinem Fall habe ich die Betrugstransaktion mit dem zweiten Faktor autorisiert,
was bei diesen Webshops und Stripes sicher auch normal wäre.
In diesem Fall kommt man an das Geld nicht wieder heran. Das steht in den Kartenbedingungen.
Alles, was per Visa Secure autorisiert wurde, ist Und ich denke es auch,
bei Mastercard ist es 3D-Secure oder so.
Ist final. Die Bank und der Zahlungsdienstleister haben kein Interesse daran,
irgendwas aufzuklären oder Chargeback auszulösen.
Ich nehme das jetzt mal so hin. Ich glaube auf jeden Fall, dass das richtig ist.
Und diese, ich glaube,
das haben wir hier auch an unterschiedlichen Stellen kritisiert,
Diese Erhöhung der Sicherheit von Zahlungsverfahren durch bessere zweite Faktoren,
wo einzelne Transaktionen signiert werden,
autorisiert werden, haben auf jeden Fall zur Folge, dass die Beweislast mehr
auf den potenziellen Opfern liegt, weil das Verfahren sicherer ist.
Also hier findet auch, kann man argumentieren, eine IT-Sicherheit gegen die
Interessen der Nutzer statt, weil die Banken quasi eine bessere Position haben zu sagen,
hier, das hast du du autorisiert, wir haben ganz klar, hat das hier stattgefunden
und uns trifft keine Schuld.
Gleichzeitig haben die natürlich trotzdem in der Regel ein Interesse,
das Vertrauen in ihren Service aufrecht zu erhalten und lassen da gerne Makulanz walten.
Aber sicherere Zahlungsverfahren sind in der Regel eigentlich gegen die Interessen der Nutzer.
Wenn man das mal, weil sie den Bedienungsfehler und die Nutzertäuschung eigentlich
als einzigen Fehlerfall noch haben.
Ja.
Ja, ist so. Also ich bin sowieso, in letzter Zeit, Tim, laufe ich durch die
Welt und gucke mir an, wo Leute Dinge machen, obwohl es keine Problemstellungen gab.
Und die Problemstellung, dass massenhaft Leute im Online-Banking oder im Online-Zahlungswesen
unter Unsicherheit gelitten hätten, die gab es einfach nie.
Es gab Täuschungen, es gab Phishing und so weiter.
Aber dass die Verfahren zu unsicher waren, darum haben sich die Banken und Zahlungsanbieter
dann schon gekümmert, dass das technisch sicher ist.
Ja, da ist was dran.
Auf mein Konto zu gucken, aber jetzt erst recht nicht.
Lass dich bei so vielen fishy Läden bestellen, das ist einfach das Problem.
Ja, das ist wirklich, also aber so eine Gucci-Tasche, deutsche und Gucci.
Ich nehme dich auch so schon nicht ernst.
Ich brauche gar nicht so eine Tasche. Nein.
So, aber das Funklochamt hat es geschafft, war erfolgreich, sich selber einzustellen.
Ja.
Die Funklöcher wiederum gibt es offenbar immer noch.
Wir erinnern uns, unser Superminister Andreas Scheuer, der also der Typ,
der wirklich so ziemlich alles alles komplett gegen die Wand gefahren hat,
was ihm irgendwie unter die Fuchtel kam.
Ich sag nur Autobahnmaut, also wo er Verträge abgeschlossen hat,
bevor das Ding juristisch durch war.
Dann kam die EU und hat gesagt, könnt ihr nicht machen und dann gab es die ganzen Verpflichtungen.
Wir waren dann regresspflichtig. Wir haben dann hunderte Millionen.
Weil die Verträge waren verbindlich und die Firmen haben gesagt,
wir haben jetzt hier schon investiert, das steht ja hier auf dem Papier,
was wollt ihr irgendwie? Könnt ihr ja klagen.
Das heißt, wir mussten dann einfach ganz viel Kohle ausgeben.
Naja, dieser Andreas Scheuer, also der Typ, der einfach jetzt auch gerade die
Politik verlässt und jetzt Berater wird,
der hat ja dann unter anderem auch dieses Thema Funklöcher dann mal entdeckt,
weil offensichtlich in seinem Heimatwahlkreis auch ein großes klaffte.
Und dann hat er halt diese Tochtergesellschaft,
gegründet. Also eine Tochtergesellschaft, genau von diesem Toll-Collect sogar.
Ja klar, das ist alles seine.
Was das eine mit dem anderen zu tun hat, ist ja...
Es sind einfach die gleichen Leute, die die Taschen aufgehalten haben.
Also wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall gab es, wie hieß denn diese...
Was war denn die offizielle Bezeichnung nochmal von diesem, es hieß ja nicht
Funklochamt, sondern es hatte ja doch, das ist nicht nochmal ein anderer Name,
Mobilfunkinfrastrukturgesellschaft.
Mobilfunkinfrastrukturgesellschaft, ja.
Genau, MIG. Und die sollte halt dafür sorgen, selber Masten zu bauen,
um halt Funklöcher zu machen.
Ich bin ja generell, bin ich ja der Meinung, dass das kein falscher Weg ist,
dass der Staat so Masteninfrastruktur aufbaut.
Ja, aber das war ja nicht… Was?
Ja, also grundsätzlich finde ich das okay. Ich bin ja immer der Meinung,
Staat, Infrastruktur, das passt einfach gut zusammen.
Und wir bauen ja auch Straßen und wir bauen auch Kraftwerke und wir bauen Abwassersysteme
und Wasserzuführungen und so weiter.
Die Infrastruktur. Und es sollte ja mittlerweile angekommen sein,
dass auch das Thema Datenübertragung eine wichtige Infrastruktur ist.
Und natürlich kann davon auch das eine oder andere privat organisiert sein,
das ist ja im Prinzip so wie es derzeit ist, im Wesentlichen,
je nachdem wie man die Telekom so bewerten möchte.
Aber es hat sich halt auch gezeigt, dass das Interesse eben nicht darin besteht,
eine Vollversorgung überall zu machen, sondern eben, wie wir das immer so sehen,
mit so und so viel Prozent der Bevölkerung nach, wo die Leute wohnen.
Was halt immer wieder absurd ist, dass man Mobilfunk danach bewertet,
dass eine Abdeckung an den Stellen ist, wo die Leute zu Hause sind.
Weil das ist ja nicht mobil.
Also mobil ist man ja unterwegs und nicht zu Hause.
Mit dem Ergebnis, dass halt an all den Orten, wo man hin wollte,
wenn man weit weg ist von zu Hause, kein Netz hat.
Naja, auf jeden Fall war das nicht so erfolgreich. Dieser MIG hat es geschafft, wie viel?
Zwei? Masten zu bauen?
Ja, aber da ist noch keine Antenne drauf oder so.
Immerhin die Masten.
Das muss man auch mal anerkennen. Also, die haben es geschafft,
da einen Mast aufzubauen. Was hat es gekostet?
200.000 Euro.
Nee, die haben ein paar Millionen verbraten.
Die hatten ein Etat von 1,1.
Milliarden. Die haben 70 Mitarbeiter. Und irgendein Campingplatz in Nordrhein-Westfalen
steht jetzt ein Mast, der sendet aber nicht. Da sind keine Antennen dran.
Es ist eine absolute Katastrophe.
Es ist ein reines Scheuer-Projekt. Die haben enorm Naumburg,
70 Mitarbeiter. 70 Mitarbeiter.
Und die haben irgendwie in zweieinhalb, drei Jahren nicht, also haben die nicht,
es gibt keinen einzigen Mast, der in Betrieb gegangen ist. Das musst du dir mal vorstellen.
Aber ich habe auch mal mit, also da konntest du ja quasi Förderanträge stellen.
Das hat aber auch keiner gemacht, weil der, weil die Überlegung,
also weil quasi die Förderung zu beantragen war so kompliziert,
dass man selbst mit dem geförderten Mast niemals hätte in irgendeiner Weise.
Ökonomisch operieren können.
Das heißt, die Hürden waren so schwer, dass die Mobilfunkanbieter gesagt haben,
lass uns, geh mir weg mit denen, das ist viel zu teuer. Also es ist ein,
begeisterndes Stück. Aber wir behandeln das ja nur, weil es eine gute Nachricht gibt.
Also das Funklochamt ist gescheitert, ja, oder wird jetzt abgewickelt,
das ist eigentlich auch eine gute Nachricht, dass wir da nur so,
niedrigen, mittleren zweistelligen Millionenbetrag jetzt verballert haben,
das ist für Andy Scheuers Dimensionen, sind das ja Peanuts, ne, also das, und jetzt,
geht es aber darum, die neuen Frequenzen für 5G, also es gibt,
800 MHz, 1,8 GHz und 2,6 6 Gigahertz.
Da gibt es noch freie Frequenzbänder, die die, jetzt will ich BaFin sagen,
REC-TP, wie heißt sie denn?
Bundesnetzagentur.
Bundesnetzagentur. Die Bundesnetzagentur verteilen möchte und sie wird es erstmals
nicht mit dem Verfahren tun, das wir hier immer kritisiert haben.
Nämlich, Tim, was machen sie nicht?
Sie versteigern das nicht.
Ne. Wahnsinn.
Sondern sie sagen, ihr kriegt einfach die Frequenzen, wir verlängern das,
wir geben sozusagen denen, die es heute schon haben, das sind also Vodafone,
Telekom, Telefonica, also in Klammern O2 und dann gibt es noch 1&1.
Also 1&1 spielt da gerade nicht mit. 1&1 ist ausgestattet. Das ist einer der
Gründe, warum die sich beschweren.
Aber die sollen jetzt sozusagen auch noch Frequenzen dazu erhalten.
Auf jeden Fall wird denen sozusagen einfach das Ganze verlängert.
Das heißt, die 2025 auslaufenden Frequenznutzungsrechte werden dann einfach
um fünf Jahre verlängert und sie müssen nicht dafür nochmal tief in die Tasche greifen.
Dafür soll aber dann erstmalig eine Bedingung erfüllt werden,
nämlich, dass diese Mobilfunkunternehmen nicht nach Bewohnerzahl,
sondern nach Fläche abdecken.
Im Gespräch sind 99,5% der Fläche in Deutschland.
Vorher war das halt immer 99% der Bevölkerung sozusagen. Und das ist ja dieser Irrsinn.
Deswegen bauen sie das in Städten.
So jetzt haben sie das aber auch eingesehen, keine 35 Jahre nachdem man mit
Mobilfunk angefangen hat in Deutschland, dass es vielleicht mal ganz gut wäre
mal so die Fläche abzudecken.
Da gibt es dann allerdings auch noch Streit drum, also das ist jetzt auch nicht
glücklich mit und wollen wieder mehr, aber grundsätzlich halte ich das natürlich
für eine gute Idee allerdings, frage ich mich halt, warum,
99,5% der Fläche und nicht 100% der Fläche.
Also ich glaube Tim, da muss man mal ganz ehrlich sein weil du,
das wird schon schwer genug noch in irgendeinem... Also 99,5...
Was denn?
0,5% der Fläche Deutschlands.
Ja, wie viel ist das? In Saarländern?
In Saarländern? Ich kann dir das in Uckermarks sagen. Das ist eine halbe Uckermark.
Ja, da will da keiner hin. Dann machen wir das da.
Ich kann auch nochmal das Saarland versuchen irgendwie...
Uckermark ist doch überhaupt keine SI-Einheit. Was ist denn Uckermark?
Also es ist 70% der Fläche des Saarlands ungefähr von 0,5%.
Und Fußballfelder?
Amerikanische oder,
metrische Fußballfelder?
Fußballfelder, gucken wir mal, wie viele Fußballfelder das wäre.
Wenn ich mich hier nicht vertue, müssen das ungefähr 250.000 Fußballfelder sein.
Also auf 250.000 Fußballfeldern gibt es dann immer noch kein Netz.
Gehst du um Fußball? Ja?
Dein Leben lang. 250.000 Meilen.
Ja, jetzt kann man noch fragen, wie viele Fußballspiele.
250.000 Auswärtsspiele im Funkloch.
Jetzt können wir nochmal rausfinden, wie viele Fußballspiele finden an einem
Wochenende in Deutschland überhaupt statt?
Das ist ja sozusagen die andere Frage. Da hast du Profifußball,
Regionalligen, Oberligen, Amateurjugendfußball und so weiter.
Das findet ja alles irgendwie statt. Und da kannst du davon ausgehen,
es gibt irgendwie so 20.000 Spiele.
Aber auf 250.000 Fußballfeldern gibt es überhaupt gar kein Netz.
Also, ich sage, wie lange muss Tim Fußball spielen?
Wie viele Fußballerkarrieren werden hier geopfert?
Ja, und denkt doch mal einer an die Uckermark, da gibt es ja jetzt schon kein
Netz und dann bleibt ja noch eine komplette Hälfte übrig.
Das geht einfach nicht. Gut, also das Entscheidende ist, dass sie hier überhaupt
eine Abkehr davon stattfinden lassen, dass diese Frequenzen meist bietend ersteigert
werden müssen. Sie nehmen trotzdem noch Geld.
Sie sagen, sie wollen niedrige Gebühren für die verlängerte Nutzung.
Die werden beziffert für die fünf Jahre rund 600 Millionen Euro.
Das heißt, 120 Millionen pro Jahr durch drei. 40 Millionen Euro nimmt die Netzagentur
denen weg in Staatssäcke.
Was ich immer noch zu viel finde.
Also finde ich immer noch zu viel. Ich finde aber und vielleicht sollte ich
hier kurz vorsichtig sagen, ich bin ja im Mobilfunkbereich tätig.
Und ich glaube, dass ich da nicht die Interessen unserer Kunden vertrete,
wenn ich sage, ich halte es für unsinnig, vier Mobilfunknetze in Deutschland zu bauen.
Über zwei hätte ich mit mir reden lassen. Ein drittes braucht wirklich keine Sau mehr.
Und ein viertes ist sicherlich keine effiziente Nutzung der Ressourcen, die der Markt hat.
Ein oder zwei 99,5% abdeckende Mobilfunknetze wären wären völlig ausreichend
und jetzt jemanden ein viertes bauen zu lassen, halte ich für eine,
Also, überleg mal, das heißt, wir haben ja dann irgendwann, oder wir hatten
ja auch schon, vier Unternehmen mit dem Ziel, ganz Deutschland abzudecken.
Mit einer Infrastruktur, die wird ja auch gebaut und betrieben.
Da muss ja jemand einen Turm hinbauen. Und wir wissen, wie schwer das ist.
Und eine Antenne hin. und dann hast du am Ende vier davon und trotzdem die vier
mussten in einem ruinösen Dieter-Wettbewerb diese Frequenzen bekommen und schaffen
es dann mit dem ganzen Geld, was ihnen weggenommen wurde,
noch nicht einmal das Land abzudecken.
Also das ist ja ein komplett kaputtes System.
Also, einfache Sache. Wir hatten ja auch diese Japaner, die dann nach Deutschland gekommen sind.
Aha, wir sind irgendwie jetzt hier aus aus Berlin raus, auf einmal,
mein Handy ist kaputt gegangen. Er hat keinen Empfang mehr.
Irgendwas ist da, da ist oben jetzt so ein Symbol. Und dann,
ja, warum habt ihr denn hier keinen Empfang? Habt ihr kein Mobilfunknetz? Nee, wir haben vier.
Ich hab hier vier Mobilfunknetze. Ich hab hier vier komplett getrennte Mobilfunknetze,
die alle hier nicht funktionieren.
Gut, ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt andere Länder das komplett anders machen würden.
Also mir ist jetzt kein Land bekannt, was da generell einen komplett anderen Ansatz hat.
Das ist doch keine Entschuldigung dafür.
Nee, es kann ja durchaus auch funktionieren mit mehreren Netzen.
Und sagen wir mal so, es gibt auch, also mindestens ein Argument ist natürlich,
dass du in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine höhere Ausfallresilienz hast.
Weil wir es schon haben, ist in Ordnung.
Ja, zwei, vielleicht sind auch drei ganz okay. Nur eben diese Probleme,
wir wären ja damit auch ganz zufrieden, wenn es einen höheren Wettbewerb gäbe.
Und eben dieses, der Staat baut eine Infrastruktur für die Fläche,
um irgendwie Lücken zu schließen und das sind dann aber auch so Shared-Geschichten
und das überhaupt auch der eigentliche Kunde und der Netzbetreiber,
dass man das vielleicht mehr trennt, das wäre halt auch noch zu überlegen.
Das hat immer so technische Implikationen. Deswegen halte ich mich jetzt da
mit einer Wertung auch nochmal ein bisschen zurück.
Grundsätzlich ist das jetzt auf jeden Fall ein guter Trend, den wir jetzt sehen.
Mal schauen, ob es wirkt, aber ich wäre halt für 100 Prozent.
Ja.
Das wäre sehr schön. Insgesamt wäre es mal schön, dass jetzt runter,
also es ist überhaupt mal ein Schritt, dass man die nicht nochmal irgendwie sagt,
passt auf, ruiniert euch erstmal in der Steigerung dieser Frequenzrechte und
dann hoffen wir mal, dass ihr eine Infrastruktur baut, dass das so nicht funktioniert,
hätte man sich vorher schon denken können.
Mal gucken, 1&1 Mosat jetzt, weil sie keine eigenen in dieser Lösung bekommen,
weil ja existierende verlängert werden.
Das heißt, da wird im Zweifelsfall Ralf Dormammuth eh nochmal eine Änderung herbeiführen.
Ja, und da vertritt ja auch 1&1 wiederum in Anführungszeichen legitime Interessen.
Die haben sich angeschickt, ein Mobilfunknetz zu bauen.
Also sollten sie das natürlich jetzt auch tun können, zu nicht bevorteilten
und nicht benachteiligten Konditionen.
Aber es ist eine Zeitenwende, Tim.
Ja ich finde schon.
Dass das ich glaube, dass das könnte eine Zeitenwende sein.
Naja, gucken, ob das mit der Zeitenwende funktioniert, bei der anderen bin ich
mir gerade noch nicht so sicher.
Dann haben wir einen neuen Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten, Ulrich Kälber.
Es war ein langes Theater um die Verlängerung seiner Amtszeit.
Wir haben darüber berichtet.
Jetzt steht die Nachfolgerin fest.
Ihr Name ist Luisa Specht-Riemenschneider. Sie hat die Forschungsstelle Datenrecht
an der Uni Bonn geleitet.
Ich glaube, der Kälber kam ja auch aus Bonn. Das heißt, es bleibt in der alten
Hauptstadt und wir sind gespannt.
Sie wird sich im Prinzip mit drei Dingen in nächster Zeit auseinandersetzen dürfen.
Natürlich dieser ganze Gesundheitsdaten-Kram, europäischer Health-Data-Space und was da alles los ist.
Staatliche Überwachung bleibt ein Thema, Vorratsdatenspeicherung und so weiter.
Und Informationsfreiheit, also Transparenz des Staates, bleibt ja auch ein Thema.
Sind wir mal gespannt, wie Luisa Specht-Riemenschneider sich dieser Aufgabe widmet.
Kompetent dafür ist sie jedenfalls und die Position, die man bisher so von ihr
gehört hat, gingen auch in die Richtung, dass sie das Amt wahrscheinlich ernst nehmen und sehr.
In guten Händen weiterführen wird, Wenn gleich wir ja alle zunächst einmal den
Weggang von Ulrich Kälber und die fachfremden Bedingungen, unter denen das passiert,
bedauern, kriegen wir wenigstens jetzt nicht so eine, wie hieß die Nummer, Voshoff oder sowas?
Ja, ja.
Klingt nicht nach einem Totalausfall, ganz im Gegenteil, wir haben eine kompetente Nachbesetzung.
Andrea Voshoff hieß die Gute. Ja.
Da gab es eine Verurteilung.
Nicht?
Ja. Und zwar Alexey P.
Und der hat ein System programmiert, eine Software, einen dezentralen Mixing-Dienst.
Macht also folgendes, es ist auf der Ethereum-Blockchain, funktioniert mit Smart
Contracts und ein Mixing-Dienst sammelt Transaktionen von Leuten in einem großen Pool,
Und verteilt die Ergebnisse, mischt das Geld und verteilt es dann auf frische
Crypto-Wallet-Adressen.
So, warum könnte man so etwas brauchen?
Darf ich vielleicht für die Leute, die in der ganzen Crypto-Geld-Debatte nicht
ganz so tief drinstecken, da nochmal einmal kurz eine Meta-Ebene drüber gehen.
Also, wenn wir von diesen ganzen Crypto-Geldern reden, gibt es halt verschiedenste
Sachen. Und jeder kennt ja Bitcoin irgendwie.
Davon haben wir schon mal gehört. Aber es gibt ja neben Bitcoin auch noch andere
solche Kryptogeldwährungen wie zum Beispiel dieses Ethereum und das hat sich
vor allem dadurch so einen Namen gemacht,
dass es diese sogenannten Smart Contracts unterstützt, das heißt man kann auf
dieser Blockchain nicht nur irgendwie speichern, wem gehört das Geld,
sondern man kann im Prinzip dort auch noch Code ablegen, der dann ausgeführt wird.
Und auf dieser technischen Basis kann man dann so Automatismen implementieren,
dass es hier mit diesem System erfolgt.
Genau, also die Ethereum-Blockchain, in der kann man Logik abbilden und Programme bauen.
Und dieses Programm oder dieser Dienst funktioniert so, es gehen ein paar Leute
hin und sagen, ich möchte folgenden Betrag von A nach B schicken,
der andere möchte folgenden Betrag von C nach D schicken.
Und jetzt wird das in einen Haufen gemacht und dort auf ganz viele neue Crypto Wallets verteilt.
Das ist das, was dieses Ding macht.
Und diese neuen Crypto Wallets, die gehören natürlich den Leuten,
die vorher das Geld da reingeworfen haben und die über diese neuen Crypto Wallets verfügen.
Weil das Geld aber gemischt wurde, hast du jetzt eine Situation,
in der die neuen Crypto-Wallets quasi denen nicht mehr nachgewiesen werden kann,
wem sie gehören und welches Geld da jetzt genau angekommen ist.
Der Teil ist quasi maskiert. Also ein System,
wo Leute reingehen, die quasi in einem Wallet oder in mindestens einem Wallet
Geld haben und sagen, ich möchte bitte, dass das Geld, was ich in diesem Wallet habe,
in ganz viele andere Wallets geht, die es vorher nicht gab und der Weg dorthin
nicht nachvollziehbar ist.
Sodass ich unter Kontrolle dieser neuen Wallets behaupten kann,
dass mein Geld nicht von dort stammt.
Also wer hat an so etwas Interesse?
Natürlich kostet, achso, das kann man natürlich noch sagen, sowas kostet dann
Geld, also Smart Contracts und die Erfüllung und so weiter, das kostet Gebühren.
Das heißt, du bezahlst dann auch noch für diesen Dienst, das ist natürlich nicht kostenlos.
Braucht gar nicht so wenig, ne?
Habe ich jetzt gerade nicht im Kopf, aber ich komme gleich dazu,
mit wie viel Geld der Typ erwischt wurde.
Wer hat an sowas Interesse? Also das, was da gebaut wurde, diese Software,
braucht man exakt für einen Zweck und dieser Zweck nennt sich Geldwäsche.
Also das ist das Verschleiern von Zahlungen.
Das ist in der Regel etwas, was Leute tun, die ja, die bei der Primärzahlung
das Problem haben, dass sie sie potenziell in den Knast bringt oder sonst was.
Oder dass es halt aus einer Ransomware-Erpressung stammt oder dass es.
Aufsonst in irgendeiner Weise für sie ein Problem wäre, anderen gegenüber zuzugeben,
dass dieses Wallet ihres ist.
Und entsprechend, weil dieser Service auch sehr beliebt in dem Gerichtsverfahren
geht, ist es darum, dass darüber ungefähr 1,2 Milliarden US-Dollar gewaschen wurden.
Sorry, das war ja alles. Die haben ja diese Gebühren nur bezahlt,
um ihr Recht auf Privatsphäre im Internet wahrzunehmen.
Im Kampf gegen die finanzielle Zensur, die in diesem Land uns allen die ganze
Zeit Probleme macht. Das waren also alles 1,2 Milliarden digitaler Freiheitskampf,
die da ermöglicht wurden.
Primär Nordkorea und Ransomware-Gangs. Der Typ, der diese Software geschrieben
hat, ist einer von dreien.
Dem wurden beschlagnahmt 1,9 Millionen in Coins und Porsche.
Kriegt er auch nicht zurück.
Also das war ja Open Source, muss man ja sagen. Open Source Software, voll geil alles.
Und ohne Gewinninteresse hat er das gemacht.
Die 1,9 Millionen, die dann in Coins bei ihm gelandet sind, die waren bestimmt
alle aus ehrlicher Lohnarbeit.
Und jetzt wurde der wegen Geldwäsche verurteilt, kann noch Rechtsmittel dagegen ergreifen.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie bewertet man das jetzt?
Ja, die, die sich dort verteidigen, haben gesagt, naja, wir haben ja erstmal
nur ein Privatsphäre-Tool gebaut und wir können ja nichts dafür,
wenn das jetzt andere nutzen für kriminelle Zwecke.
Und das ist ja eine Argumentation, die mir zunächst einmal sympathisch ist.
Also du baust ein System für verschlüsselte E-Mails, gibt es eine ganze Reihe
legitimer Anwendungszwecke für.
Du baust Tor-Hidden-Services, Onion-Services, gibt es eine ganze Reihe legitimer
Anwendungszwecke für und Nutzungszwecke. Ja, es wird auch von Kriminellen benutzt,
das ist ärgerlich, aber du kannst ja deiner Technologie,
nicht zur Last legen, dass sie auch von Kriminellen benutzt wird.
Hier scheint aber das Gericht die Perspektive zu vertreten, dass es eigentlich
schwer nachvollziehbar ist, was ein legitimer, nicht krimineller Anwendungsfall wäre.
Also das ist ja immer so eine Debatte mit diesem ganzen Kryptogeld und es gibt
da einfach so eine Fraktion, die irgendwie der Meinung ist,
man müsse jetzt Finanzströme jenseits staatlicher Kontrolle ermöglichen, wegen Freiheit.
Und ich kann diese Argumentation ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig abgewinnen,
weil das scheint mir dann doch eher so ein theoretisches Problem zu sein.
Gerade in dieser ganzen Kryptogeld Welt wird dann halt schnell,
gewedelt mit irgendwelchen Social Media Leuten,
die sonst irgendwie in ihrem Land nichts machen könnten oder irgendwelche Leute,
die irgendwelche Kleinkredite bekommen in Indien,
ja, die sie alle aber auch ohne Kryptogeld bekommen könnten und so ein richtig
großes Problem ist es nicht und am Ende geht es eigentlich immer um was anderes.
Es geht einfach darum, mit diesem System einfach maximal Leute zu bescheißen.
Wir haben das in den letzten Jahren einfach gesehen, was das alles gebracht
hat in dieser ganzen Kryptowelt.
Hagelt es von.
Kryptogeld, Diebstahl, Beschiss, pleitegegangenen Projekten,
dieser ganze NFT-Betrug, der in den letzten Jahren stattgefunden hat,
ein System, was keinerlei wirtschaftlichen Nutzen hat, was auch überhaupt gar keinen Sinn ergibt.
Wenn man sich mal anschaut, was da eigentlich gemacht wird, also dieses Tokenisierung
von irgendwelchen Bildern oder so, Memes wurden da verkauft für irrsinniges
Geld, aber eben auch immer nur von Leuten gekauft, die halt.
Letzten Endes mehr dafür wiederum von anderen Leuten haben wollten.
Das ist so ein Schneeballsystem und das bricht dann irgendwann zusammen und
es bricht heutzutage auch zusammen.
Jetzt kommen natürlich Leute und sagen, ja, aber die Kurse gehen ja immer noch
hoch. Ja, weil das halt einfach immer solche Pump-and-Dump-Schemes sind.
Da wird über verschiedenste Methoden dieser Kurs beeinflusst und am Ende verdienen
dann halt einfach immer wieder, wie sagst du mal so schön, die Leute,
die die Schaufeln für den Goldrush verkaufen.
Und wir haben es auch gesehen hier, Sam Bankman-Fried so als sichtbarstes Beispiel
eines komplett zusammengebrochenen Trading, einer Trading-Plattform,
der jetzt verknackt worden ist.
Und da werden noch so einige andere folgen.
Das bringt uns keine Freiheit, sondern das macht uns eher Probleme.
Das ist ein Vehikel, wo Rogue States jetzt hohe Gelder zugespielt werden,
die sie dann benutzen, um davon Waffen zu kaufen, um sie irgendwie Russland
zu liefern, damit die das irgendwie über der Ukraine abregnen lassen.
Also ich habe da keinerlei Sympathie.
Vielleicht bleiben wir aber ganz kurz nochmal bei dem Thema der Verurteilung wegen Geldwäsche.
Also, Herzsache ist, Nordkorea finanziert mit Kryptodiebstählen,
in Milliardenhöhe sein Atomprogramm. Wir wissen,
Nordkorea von einer irren Familie in Isolation und Diktatur gezwungenes Land und diese Diktatur,
die ja international in zunehmendem Maße isoliert ist,
hat zwei Primärinteressen.
Das eine ist, Atomwaffen zu bekommen um sich dauerhaft des Risikos zu entledigen,
irgendwann einfach überrannt zu werden von anderen.
Oder eben, dass das Land befreit wird. Es ist völlig klar, dass die nach Nuklearwaffen streben.
Und das andere ist, weil sie international vollständig isoliert sind und keiner
ihre Währung haben will, haben die einen sehr starken Bedarf an US-Dollar.
Weil nur damit können die sich auf dem internationalen Markt was kaufen.
Und selbst das natürlich nur
unter starken Einschränkungen, Umgehung von Exportkontrolle und so weiter.
Ja, und genau das machen die und dann haben sie sich halt festgestellt,
was ist eine der einfachsten Möglichkeiten oder eine vielversprechende Möglichkeit,
an US-Dollar zu kommen, ist halt die zu klauen.
Und wenn du die klaust, was brauchst du dann, um sie irgendwie am Ende auch
wirklich gegen US-Dollar tauschen zu können? Du brauchst einen Geldwäscheservice.
Und der wurde hier jetzt von diesen Leuten gebaut. Jetzt kann man,
wie gesagt, die Argumentation führen, du hast ein Privatsphäre-Tool in die Welt
gesetzt, ist in Ordnung.
Mit diesem Privatsphäre-Tool haben die aber Geld verdient.
Also anfangs haben sie direkt damit Geld verdient, dann haben sie das in eine
Decentralized Autonomous Organization überführt, bei der sie aber den größeren
Teil der Stimmrechte hatten.
Das heißt, das war dann auch wieder nur so eine Dezentralisierungssimulation,
die ja dann immer bei diesen dezentralen Systemen als nächstes kommt.
Ja, da können wir alle einen Anteil haben, ja viel Spaß, derjenige,
der 51 Prozent hat, muss es aber gar nicht quasi, noch nicht mal wirklich öffentlich
sagen, dass er die kontrolliert, weil ja alles an und für sich pseudonym sein kann.
Es war außerdem wohl klar, dass die wissen, wofür dieser Dienst benutzt wird.
Aus Chats und Skripts, die sie zur Sperre eingebaut haben, haben sie so gebaut,
dass man die wieder rausnehmen konnte.
Ähm, ja. Und jetzt gibt's halt auf der einen Seite die Leute,
die sagen, hier, das ist ein schwieriger Dammbruch, weil der hat ja nur eine Software geschrieben.
Und diese Software war gut, weil sie finanzielle Freiheit schafft.
Und auf der anderen Seite die, die sagen, ey, der hat für wirklich unsere Feinde,
Hacker, die uns erpressen, Nordkorea, Geld gewaschen und dafür Geld genommen.
Ich glaube, dass der Fall im Zweifelsfall so zu bewerten ist,
dass er beides gemacht hat und vor allem damit uns geschadet hat.
Ja, diejenigen, die für einen Schutz des Individuums eintreten wollen,
die natürlich auch für Freiheiten von Überwachung und Kontrolle eintreten möchten,
aber dann solche Leute da sitzen haben, die sich einfach mal zum Millionär machen,
indem sie Geld waschen für Nordkorea.
What the fuck? Also das sind doch nicht meine Freunde. Für die muss ich auch nicht einstehen.
Nee, muss man nicht. Und auf der anderen Seite sehe ich halt einfach auch keinen
Beweis dafür, dass solches System jetzt irgendeinen nennenswerten Freiheitsgewinn darf.
Natürlich nicht.
Zahlen. Und erstmal sehr, sehr, sehr sekundär das Interesse,
dass man irgendwo in einer Diktatur lebt, wo dieser Geldfluss jetzt zensiert wird.
Das gibt es auch, aber es gibt erstmal jeder Mensch, der Steuern zahlt,
hat da keinen Bock drauf.
Und entsprechend,
kann man sich anschauen, wo.
Die Geldwäsche Oder auch das kriminelle Kapital sich unterbringt.
Übrigens primär inzwischen in Europa, in Deutschland.
Weil du in Deutschland mit Bargeld ein Haus kaufen kannst.
Gehst zum Notar mit einer Tasche, unterschreiben beide ja Geld, alles klar, fertig.
In vielen anderen Ländern würde irgendwo jemand sagen, oh guck mal,
eine Sporttasche mit einer Million drin.
Aus welchem Bankschließfach hast du die denn geholt? In Deutschland sagen wir,
Sporttasche mit einer Million drin. Geil.
Zahl mal Gebühr, fertig, weiter geht's. Also wenn du dir diese Mafia-Podcasts
mal anhörst, die sich das alles anschauen, die italienische Mafia investiert
ja größtenteils in Deutschland, weil man ihnen in Italien den Hahn zugedreht hat.
Da wird für jeden keine Buchung ohne Beleg und die kriegen einfach ihr ganzes
Geld nirgendwo mehr ausgegeben.
Außer in Deutschland.
Da wird es zumindest in den Mengen, wie sie es ausgeben müssen.
Auch bar angenommen.
Und dann haben wir hier steigende Immobilienpreise. Das ist doch auch schön.
Ja, das ist glaube ich noch ein größeres, ein vielfacettenartigeres Problem,
aber vor allem haben wir einfach die Immobilien in den Händen von irgendwelchen
kriminellen Arschlöchern.
Und der italienischen Mafia. und der italienischen Mafia.
Naja.
Läuft.
Ja.
Naja, also ich glaube, man muss bei dem Einstehen, bei den Privatsphäre,
kämpfen, auch irgendwie nochmal überlegen, wer,
kämpft da auf meiner Seite. Ja, und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt,
dass die Jungs nicht auf unserer Seite waren.
Wer aber auf unserer Seite kämpft, sind unsere Freunde vom Volksverpetzer.
Das stimmt.
Übrigens, ich weiß gar nicht, so lange gibt es die noch gar nicht und die haben
da wirklich eine relativ,
also auch relativ schnell gewachsen, hatte ich so den Eindruck,
innerhalb der letzten Jahre.
Ein Blog, Was ich schon größtenteils, ja, wo liegt der Fokus?
Auf jeden Fall sehr genau auf die faschistischen Tendenzen im Land schauen.
Auf jeden Fall sehr auf die Fake-Nachrichten.
Ja, was also im Bereich der Corona-Pandemie haben sich sehr auch damit mit Hass,
Hetze, Fake News Verschwörungstheorien und so auseinandergesetzt und ja das
kommt natürlich dann am Ende,
Laufen da viele Fäden halt dann auch bei den Faschisten zusammen und entsprechend
sind sie denen natürlich auch ein Dorn im Auge.
Also die gibt es jetzt schon seit 10 Jahren, ist mal als Blog gestartet worden,
hat sich so generell mit Fake News, Hasshetze und so weiter auseinandergesetzt.
2016, 17 waren sie bei Mimikama sozusagen untergekommen, das ist ja ein entsprechendes
Projekt aus Österreich, was auch schon sehr lange gibt und 2018 sind sie dann unabhängig.
Also jetzt quasi seit 5, 6 Jahren unter dem Namen Volksverpetzer,
also ich weiß nicht, ob es von Anfang an schon so hieß, ich glaube ja,
aber sozusagen als eigenständige Organisation.
Fallen immer wieder auf, auch durch so ein besonders, wie ich finde,
was ist denn die richtige Bezeichnung dafür, also eine sehr starke,
meinungsstarke Online-Präsenz.
Also es ist jetzt nicht nur so ein Fakten-Ticker, sondern die sind dann auch
präsent und haben ein interessantes Auftreten, sagen wir es mal so.
Sie haben also gerne mal reißerische Titel,
die dann aber mit verhältnismäßig langen und sauberen Artikeln gefolgt werden.
Also sie scheinen das heutige Social-Media-Game ganz gut zu verstehen.
Jemand anderes, der auch ähnlich, würde ich mal sagen, arbeitet,
ist der dunkle Parabelritter, der auch, wenn du dir diese YouTube...
Teaser anschaust, die Titel und die Grafiken, die der hat, da denkst du echt,
oh, was ist das denn jetzt?
Und dann kommen aber sehr differenzierte und gut recherchierte Einlassungen zum Thema.
Meinungsstark, aber das,
kritisieren wir ja nicht, solange die Fakten stimmen.
Ja, das ist ja dann auch heutzutage einfach auch eine Realität,
dass du jetzt in den Algorithmen getriebenen Systemen, gerade wie YouTube,
musst du halt immer hohe Klick-Anreize liefern und das läuft nun mal heute über das Thumbnail.
Also Thumbnail-Design ist schon mal eine eigene Wissenschaft mittlerweile.
Und das gilt sicherlich auch genauso für textbasierte Social-Media-Posts.
Ja, und da musst du dann halt dick auftragen. Dann kannst du danach die Stimme
wieder ein bisschen senken.
Ich bin da kein großer Freund davon.
Wir machen das ja hier nicht. Wir versuchen unsere Nische anders zu bespielen.
Wir geben uns außen seriösen Anstrich und poltern dann einfach nur innen rum.
Oder? Genau, andersrum machen wir das.
Andersrum, ja.
Also okay, ich hab jetzt mal in ihren Shop geschaut. Da gibt's Fuck AfD-Socken,
Fuck Nazis-Socken, Lebe steht so, dass die AfD etwas dagegen hat.
Fuck AfD, Hoodie. Klar kannst du Nazi sein, aber du bist halt Kacke.
Also die haben da eine relativ klare Positionierung.
Aber es sind auch die Bestseller.
Da muss man ja auch sagen, warum habt ihr denn nur Anti-AfD-Sachen?
Können Sie sagen, klickt sich halt gut. Das verkauft sich halt gut.
Ist ja auch in Ordnung. So, was ist denen passiert?
Die haben dieses Ding aufgezogen,
als gemeinnützig.
Und jetzt wurde ihnen diese Gemeinnützigkeit entzogen. Das ist übrigens,
also vielleicht sollten wir ganz kurz nochmal Gemeinnützigkeit erklären.
Du kannst sagen, du bist eine gemeinnützige Stiftung, Verein,
GmbH, was auch immer für eine Organisationsform und dann bist du, musst du.
Und sicherstellen, dass du bestimmten als gemeinnützig anerkannten Zwecken,
Dienst und deine Mittel auch dementsprechend verwendest.
Und in den Gesetzen oder in den, ich weiß nicht, ob es in den Gesetz,
ja doch wahrscheinlich sogar im Gesetz, in der Bürokratie ist relativ fest klar
gesetzt, was ein gemeinnütziger Zweck ist und was nicht.
Und du musst dann eben denen entsprechen. Da kannst du irgendwie so Völkerverständigung,
Bildung oder sowas kannst du dann da reinschreiben.
Dann musst du sagen, wir haben ja eine Organisation, dann wird das irgendwann
anerkannt und dann wird das geprüft.
2021 wurde es bei denen geprüft und jetzt haben sie ein Schreiben bekommen,
dass sie keine Spendenquittung mehr ausstellen dürfen.
Denn die Folge von Du bist gemeinnützig ist, dass du erst steuerlich begünstigt
bist und dass Zuwendungen, die du bekommst, steuerlich geltend gemacht werden können.
Also Beispiel, wenn ihr an Logbuch Netzpolitik spendet, dann ist das eine private
Schenkung an uns, kriegt ihr keinen Beleg drüber, euer Problem könnt ihr auch
nicht steuerlich geltend machen.
Wenn ihr an den Volksverpetzer spendet, könnt ihr diese Spende in der,
jetzt kommt da ein Einsatz zum Einkommensteuererklärung, geltend machen und
dann ist das, das bedeutet dann,
es wird euch diese Ausgabe vollständig angerechnet, das heißt ihr kriegt die
Steuern auf diese Ausgabe nicht berechnet mit anderen Worten,
je nachdem was euer Steuersatz ist,
diesen Anteil des Geldes bekommt ihr zurück.
Genau, kann irgendwas von 15 bis 40 Prozent bedeuten kann.
Ja, genau.
Es ist wie eine Betriebsausgabe, aber es ist, glaube ich, noch mal interessanter
oder noch einfacher spürbarer für Leute, die nicht selbstständig sind.
Die kriegen nämlich dann tatsächlich, sagen, keine Ahnung, ich habe hier 100
Euro an diesen gemeinnützigen Zweck gespendet und dann kriegst du am Ende,
wenn du dann eine Einkommensteuererklärung machst, was weiß ich,
beispielsweise 30 Euro zurück. Das ist schon,
sehr wichtig.
Und hat natürlich Konsequenzen auch für die Spender, weil die potenziell natürlich deswegen mehr spenden.
Und jetzt wird dem Volksverpetzer gesagt, die können seit dem 23.
April rückwirkend keine Spendenquittung mehr ausstellen.
Das heißt, wer denen jetzt seitdem Geld gespendet hat, das ist jetzt ungefähr
ein Monat, kriegt da jetzt keine Spendenquittung für, sagen sie ja,
okay, pass auf, meldet euch, kriegt da zurück oder was auch immer.
Ja, das ist noch ein bisschen schlimmer, weil die Gemeinnützigkeit nicht nur
jetzt zum April 24 endet, sondern rückwirkend bis 2021.
Das hat dann vermutlich keine Auswirkung auf die Spende, weil die haben ja das
mal bestätigt bekommen und das ist dann dementsprechend auch anerkannt worden
und dann wird jetzt nicht die Einkommensteuererklärung gemacht.
Dann müssen sie die Steuern zahlen.
Aber der Volksverpetzer muss unter Umständen Nachzahlungen leisten.
Hier wird von einem hohen fünfstelligen Betrag geredet. Das kann sehr gut sein.
Und das ist ja auch generell so ein Problem in unserer Gesellschaft,
dass diese Anerkennung der Gemeinnützigkeit eben auch rückwirkend entzogen werden
kann. Und das ist natürlich dann so immer das Damoklesschwert eigentlich über jede Organisation.
Und konkret beim Volksverletzter besteht natürlich das Problem,
dass eben diese Tätigkeit, diese journalistische Tätigkeit eben eigentlich keine
unmittelbare direkte Begründung ist für eine Gemeinnützigkeit,
sondern du erhältst die quasi nur durch eine etwas,
naja, durch so eine,
Interpretation der,
Gemeinnützigkeitsregeln, weil es gibt halt nicht den Absatz in der Regelung
mit, wenn du Journalismus machst, der gemeinnützig ist, dann können wir das auch anerkennen.
Journalismus ist sozusagen so gar nicht vorgesehen. Das gilt auch für viele andere Dinge.
Wir haben das auch im Bereich Open Source, da wird das ja auch schon länger,
argumentiert, dass es ja sehr wohl eine gemeinnützige Tätigkeit sein kann,
offene Software zu entwickeln, die kostenlos von jedem lizenzfrei genutzt werden
kann, weil man damit irgendwie ein Ökosystem unterstützt.
Für Nido Cash zum Beispiel.
Dient der Völkerverständigung. Grenzenloser Austausch.
Friede mit Nordkorea. Oh Mann, ja. Okay. Ja, also.
Sorry, ich lasse mich ganz kurz hier einen Einwurf machen, Tim. Bevor jetzt,
Leute meinen, dass wir irgendwie Open Source Entwickler bashen oder so.
Das ist nicht der Fall. Es geht nur darum, nur weil etwas Open Source ist,
ist es weder gut noch böse.
Es gibt eine ganze Reihe echt geiler Open Source, verhältnismäßig böser Software
oder verhältnismäßig interessanter Software.
Open Source ist nicht automatisch gut oder schlecht und auch nicht automatisch
gemeinnützig oder nicht.
Das ist der Zweck der Software, der dann nochmal dabei berücksichtigt werden muss.
Sorry, das wollte ich nur sagen, weil wenn wir Open Source sagen und danach
lachen, dann kriegen wir immer böse E-Mails.
Ja, Hackback sozusagen.
Hackback E-Mails. Da gehen plötzlich mal die reihenweise die Server aus.
So ist das nämlich. Du wirst gar nicht wissen, was ihr damit anstellt.
Ach, ja.
Ich erinnere noch, ich glaube, das habe ich ja auch schon oft erzählt,
als der Verein Digitale Gesellschaft gegründet wurde, der wollte,
der ist ja auch nach meiner Wahrnehmung gemeinnützig, oder war es zumindest,
ja doch, natürlich ist er das.
Und der hat dann als Vereinszweck in die Satzung geschrieben,
Förderung von Grund- und Freiheitsrechten und dann gab es eine Ablehnung vom
Finanzamt die gesagt haben, die Förderung von Grund- und Freiheitsrechten ist
kein gemeinnütziger Zweck und das stimmt, weil,
gemeinnützige Zwecke ist eine abschließende Liste und du musst halt einen davon nehmen.
Ja, es ist vor allem auch immer bedenklich, wenn man sich so anschaut,
was alles so gemeinnützig anerkannt ist in Deutschland.
Ja, da kannst du sehr staunen. Ja, also das ist, da kannst du natürlich,
also gerade was so im Bereich Stiftungen und so, aber lassen wir das mal.
Warum dieser Fall so spannend ist, ist, dass die Ampelkoalition in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
ja gesagt hat, wir müssen die Gemeinnützigkeit in Deutschland reformieren.
Und das Ziel ist, wir modernisieren das Gemeinnützigkeitsrechts,
um der entstandenen Unsicherheit nach der Gemeinnützigkeitsrechtsprechung des
Bundesfinanzberufs entgegenwirken und konkretisieren und ergänzen gegebenenfalls
hierzu auch die einzelnen Gemeinnützigkeitszwecke,
die von denen ich gerade sprach.
Wir verbinden dies mit Transparenzpflichten für größere Organisationen.
Wir verankern eine Ansprechpartnerin bzw. einen Ansprechpartner für die Kultur-
und Kreativwirtschaft bei der Bundesregierung.
Wir schaffen Rechtssicherheit für gemeinnützigen Journalismus und machen E-Sport gemeinnützig.
Das waren die beiden großen Probleme, die wir in Deutschland hatten.
Dass der E-Sport nicht gemeinnützig war.
Naja, ich glaube, da geht es dabei darum, dass die Sportvereine natürlich größtenteils
gemeinnützig sind. Und wenn jetzt so ein E-Sport-Verein.
Ja, also da kann ich sogar noch mitgehen, ja.
Das ist auch in Ordnung, das klingt aber natürlich so, wenn jetzt irgendwie
gemeinnütziger Journalismus ein hehres Ziel und dann kommt wieder irgendein
FDP und E-Sport und E-Fuel oder irgendein Scheiß.
Aber okay, genau, das machen gemeinnützig, ja.
Ich meine, bisher war ja so diese Vorstellung, dass man Journalismus überhaupt
unabhängig betreiben kann, war ja schon schwierig.
In der Geschichte war man da eigentlich immer bei einem Verlag angesiedelt,
das war halt automatisch auch immer ein kommerzielles Interesse.
Und niemand hat jetzt irgendwie ein, ich meine das erste Projekt,
was vielleicht ansatzweise in diese Richtung geht,
das ist jetzt mit großem Vorbehalten, war so die Taz, die so ein bisschen gesagt
hat, wir wollen jetzt mal hier so einen anderen Journalismus haben, etc.
Aber im Wesentlichen haben die sich ja auch da an dem gängigen Verlagsmodell
orientiert. Aber jetzt...
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, eine Genossenschaft, aber gemeinnützig wäre die
Taz jetzt sicherlich auch nicht.
Nein, nein, ich wollte nur sagen, wo das erste Mal so eine Abkehr von der normalen
kommerziellen Ausrichtung gemacht wurde, eben durch dieses Genossenschaftsmodell.
So und jetzt haben wir aber eben so Entitäten wie Korrektiv,
die sich also noch mehr aus diesem Verlagsgedanken verabschieden und andere
Modelle liefern und die vor allem dann im zunehmenden Maße spendenbasiert arbeiten.
Ich meine, dieses ganze spendenbasierte Arbeiten ist ja nun durch das Internet
überhaupt erst zu einem Ding geworden.
Das fing ja eigentlich so vor 15 Jahren überhaupt erst an,
wenn ich mich noch zurück erinnere, als ich hier mit der Meta-Ebene angefangen
habe zu wirken und mir zu überlegen, wie kann man das jetzt hier sustainen, auch finanziell.
Da war ja die Skepsis gegenüber solchen Spendenmodellen extrem groß.
Also das hat ja keiner verstanden. Die einzige Option, die man immer sah,
war Werbung und das war es dann eigentlich im Wesentlichen.
Aber dass sich so etwas wirklich tragen könnte, ist kein Ding gewesen und dann
hat es eben eine Weile gebraucht und heutzutage, wenn du dich mal umschaust,
also es gibt so viele YouTuber,
die ihre Art von teilweise eben auch Journalismus,
oft natürlich auch einfach Unterhaltung und andere Sachen, aber oft sind es
ja auch schon auch engagierte Leute, die in bestimmten Themen unterwegs sind,
die sich natürlich dann auch bei YouTube jetzt konkret mit Werbung finanzieren.
Aber manche eben auch bewusst nicht.
Die sagen, ich will das nicht machen und ich basiere meine ganze Tätigkeit eben
nur auf der Öffentlichkeit.
Und das kann dann eben auch an so einen Punkt kommen, wo man sagen kann,
ja okay, das ist dann eben vielleicht auch wirklich gemeinnützig in gewisser
Hinsicht, weil es eben keine primären kommerziellen Interessen verfolgt.
Und das Problem wird ja noch größer, wenn wir uns jetzt anschauen,
dass im Prinzip die gesamte Medienbranche seit vielen Jahren bedroht ist und
durch so Chat-GPT und derartige Scherze,
die demnächst diese Informationen einfach nur ingesten und da gar keinen mehr
hinschicken und das ja auch zu ihrem klaren Ziel machen,
zu ihrem erklärten Ziel machen, ist es sicherlich sinnvoll...
Rechtssicherheit für gemeinnützigen Journalismus zu schaffen.
Also alternativ kannst du dir dann eine Branche anschauen, die entweder nur
noch irgendwelche Scheiße verballert, wie es eben durch diese Werbung und so der Fall ist,
oder die es dann eben im seriösen Format einfach nicht mehr gibt,
weil sie sich keiner mehr leisten kann.
Das heißt, dass diese journalistische Tätigkeit, sofern sie ohne Standards genügt,
gemeinnützig zu machen, wird früher oder später eine Notwendigkeit sein,
um Journalismus zu retten.
Gleichzeitig darf man aber auch nicht vergessen, dass natürlich die Gemeinnützigkeit,
dass das geprüft wird, ist gut, damit nicht jeder Idiot hingeht und sagt,
ich deklariere jetzt mal hier etwas als gemeinnützig und spare massenhaft Steuern.
Und deswegen gehen die dann hin, Und prüfen das. Und das ist auch richtig.
Und deswegen wird regelmäßig Organisationen die Gemeinnützigkeit aberkannt.
Die Frage ist dann, mit welcher Begründung.
Das würde ich mir mal anschauen. Ich glaube aber jetzt nicht,
dass beim Volksverpetzer irgendwie groß, da wird es eher um die Zwecke gehen und um die Tätigkeit.
Natürlich dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen, also korrektiv zum Beispiel,
sicherlich wird bei denen jetzt auch die Gemeinnützigkeit geprüft werden.
Ganz klar. Die haben sich weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt und die haben sich eine
ganze Menge Feinde gemacht und da wird jetzt auch natürlich wieder drauf geschaut werden.
Das finde ich auch erstmal richtig, weil du natürlich dieses potenzielle Steuervermeidungsmodell
auch trockenlegen musst.
Ja, insofern Prüfungen gut,
Rechtsunsicherheit für gemeinnützigen Journalismus abschaffen ist dringend notwendig
und wir sehen es jetzt an dem Fall des Volksverpetzers,
wo ich mir sicher bin, dass das etwas ist, was man auf jeden Fall unter gemeinnützig buchen möchte.
Also es ist natürlich eine schwierige Debatte, kann ich auch verstehen.
Wir hatten ja auch den Fall von Attac, die ja sozusagen als Kampagnenorganisation,
sagen wir mal, schon auch eine klare, das ist ja immer so ein bisschen das Problem,
eine klare politische Position.
Position hat. Und da kann man natürlich sagen, naja, aber wenn man ja für die
Freiheit ist und wenn man für irgendwie Grundrechte ist, dann ist das ja sozusagen für alle.
Andererseits ist natürlich auch kein Geheimnis, dass viele dieser Organisationen
im politischen Spektrum sich eher so im linksmittigen Bereich aufhalten.
Und da entsteht der Streit, dass du jetzt eben nicht diesen Weg gehen willst
und derzeit gibt es eben diesen Gegentrend,
alles was in Anführungsstrichen politisch ist, nicht als gemeinnützig anzuerkennen.
Damit jetzt weder Horst seinen politischen Aktivismus unter dem Deckmantel der
Gemeinnützigkeit führt, aber dann eben sehr wohl eine klare politische Agenda verfolgt.
Und das ist natürlich ein Spannungsfeld, gar keine Frage. Also wichtig ist,
dass das in die Debatte kommt,
dass das irgendwie auch weiterhin argumentiert wird und man eben auch vielleicht
mal in dieser ganzen Debatte auch mal klare Leitlinien definiert,
was denn sozusagen auch eine Gemeinnützigkeit absichert.
Also was sind wirklich diese Kernelemente und was sind die Anforderungen an
so eine Organisation, dass eben die Öffentlichkeit auch klar sagen kann,
ja okay, das ist etwas, was wir haben wollen.
Ich meine, wir haben auch einen öffentlichen Rundfunk, der sozusagen schon so
eine Sonderrolle hat, dadurch, dass er staatsfinanziert ist.
Ist der politisch unabhängig? Ja, vielleicht.
Wir fördern das ja auch. Was könnte es für alternative journalistische Modelle
geben, die demselben Anspruch genügen können, müssen?
Zum Beispiel Gemeinnützigkeit und da gibt es jetzt eine Petition,
die haben wir auch verlinkt und wir hoffen, dass sich die Situation für den
Volksverpetzer bald wieder klärt.
Kommen noch ein paar kurze Meldungen. Die Domain Fritzbox gehört jetzt wieder AVM.
Haben im Schiedsverfahren gewonnen, weil derjenige, der die Domain geholt hat, war böswillig.
Genau. John Doe. Könnte auch nicht ausfindig gemacht werden, Denn komischerweise.
Aber Gratulation an AVM, dass ihr die Domain jetzt habt, die ihr eigentlich
von Anfang an hättet schon kaufen müssen.
Ja. Die euch kostenlos, die euch eigentlich gesquattet habt,
als es sie noch nicht gab.
Ja, stimmt. Habt euch eigentlich nur so reingemogelt.
Und dann gibt es, machen wir mal eine Empfehlung.
Aber ich sag auch direkt, dass wir diese Empfehlung nur unter bestimmten Bedingungen machen.
Netzpolitik.org hat einen Podcast, eine Podcast-Serie produziert,
die jetzt veröffentlicht wird, mit dem Titel Systemeinstellung.
Und ich finde das sehr interessant.
Thema ist, wenn der Staat bei dir einbricht, also Leute, die plötzlich ins Visier
des Staates geraten sind.
Wir treffen unter anderem eine Klimaaktivistin, die sich als 15-Jährige vor
der Polizei bis auf die Unterwäsche ausziehen muss, einen Stadtsoziologen,
der zuerst verhaftet und dann per Hubschrauber quer durch Deutschland transportiert wird.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wer das wohl ist. Ich kenne nur einen.
Und eine engagierte Pfarrerin auf dem Land, die ihre Kirche für Geflüchtete
in Not öffnet. Also Eingriffe des Staates in die Freiheitsrechte von Leuten.
Man kann natürlich sich hier vorstellen, dass das eher dann bei Leuten ist,
die nicht tatsächlich kriminell sind, sondern eher kriminalisiert wurden.
Ein Podcast über erschüttertes Vertrauen und Ohnmacht gegenüber dem System.
Finde ich,
Ein sehr spannendes Thema. Finde ich sehr gut, dass Sie das gefunden haben,
sich das auch mal anzuschauen, weil tatsächlich die Geschichte des Stadtsoziologen,
die ist mir zwar noch präsent, weil ich den kenne und weil der an meiner Universität war,
aber die ist auch jetzt wahrscheinlich 15, 20 Jahre bald her.
Und dabei auch aktuellere Geschichten zu erzählen, finde ich einen sehr guten
Ansatz und deswegen empfehlen wir den ungehört.
Aber der ist von Netzpolitik.org und wenn euch dieses System,
wenn euch diese Produktion gefällt, dann müsst ihr das Geld dafür an uns spenden.
Ja, weil...
Ausgleichende Gerechtigkeit.
Es wird die ganze Zeit an Netzpolitik.org für uns gespendet,
weil Leuten Logbook Netzpolitik gefällt, die dann irgendwie sagen,
ja, ich bin seit Jahren unterstütze ich Netzpolitik.org und schreiben uns dann
E-Mails, ja, ich bin hier jedes Jahr Butter, ich bei Netzpolitik.org, Lino, super Sache.
Und das ist dann, wie nennt man das? Cringe. Das ist Cringe. Ja, und deswegen.
Das die richtige Nutzung des Wortes ist. Bist du überhaupt noch sicher genug?
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine Situation, in der ich dann in der Regel es nicht
übers Herz bringen zu sagen, so Rudi, ich will, ändere mal deinen Dauerauftrag
und wir sind nicht gemeinnützig.
Genau, deswegen gibt es heute nochmal einen Link in den Shownotes auf unsere Spendenseite.
Ja genau, also direkt bei wenn es an Systemeinstellungen gefällt,
müsst ihr dann uns spenden, dann machen wir direkt einen Spendenlink drunter
und dann ist das jetzt geklärt.
Nein, aber ich finde es wirklich gut, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen und dieses
Thema zu beleuchten. Bin sehr gespannt. Ich glaube, zehn Folgen sind es.
Die ersten zwei sind jetzt veröffentlicht.
Ich glaube, da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, das zu hören.
Ja, klang sehr aufwendig produziert.
Ja, da hat Anna sich, glaube ich, unter anderem also Anna, die hohe Chefredakteurin
von Netz für Dick Org, sehr reingehängt.
Mit ihrem Team, selbstverständlich. So. Termine.
Haben wir noch einen, aber ohne Musik jetzt, weil es gab so viel Streit darüber,
ob die jetzt laut oder leise ist.
Mir ist es letztes Mal, es war so ein bisschen so ein kleiner Systemunfall mit
dem, mit der Lautstärke.
Ich wollte es eigentlich, hab es extra leiser gemacht und dann im letzten Moment
noch einen Fehler gemacht.
Immer so dieses Problem. Also, verkünden wir nur einen Termin,
nachdem wir letztes Mal ganz viele hatten. Ne, zwei. Was, zwei?
Ja. 31. August in Berlin ist ein Termin, der hiermit nochmal verkündet.
Ja, genau.
Und dann findet davor vom 24. bis 28.
7. Juli das diesjährige Hexogreen-Camp in Luxemburg statt, das unter dem Titel
Bonfire Gathering Protocol, also nicht Border Gateway, sondern,
Bonfire Gathering Protocol.
20 Kilometer von der Stadt Luxemburg entfernt. Gibt noch Tickets.
Und relativ kleines Event mit circa 150 Teilnehmenden.
Und unter haxogreen.lu könnt ihr euch dafür anmelden.
Und übrigens derjenige, der uns darauf hinweist, grüßt aus dem Saarland.
Aber aus dem Viertel, was demnächst dann Netz hat.
Vielleicht.
Okay.
Warst du das schon mal bei den Luxemburgern?
Ich war schon öfter in Luxemburg, aber nicht bei dem Camp, nein.
Ich auch noch nicht. Mal gucken, da könnten wir ja vorher noch vorbeischauen, sozusagen.
Als alte Camper, die wir sind, schauen wir noch mal vorbei.
Kann schon sein.
Lagerfeuer-Zusammenkunftsprotokoll. Klingt doch schon mal ganz gut.
Dann war es das, oder?
Ich denke, das war es.
Ja, genau. Dann wünschen wir euch einen immer schöner werdenderen Sommer und
Frühling, was sich hier so anbahnt. Das ist ganz nett.
24,8 Grad steht hier gerade auf meinem Display. Geil.
Draußen.
Auf meinem steht, ich habe das gerade wieder eingepackt. 24,8 Grad steht bei mir auch. Unglaublich.
Kannst du mal sehen. Wir beziehen wahrscheinlich die Information beim selben Server.
Beim gleichen, beim gleichen. Nee, das ist ohne Server. Das ist ein Tempor...
Innenraum. Oder vielleicht.
Im Innenraum hast du 24,8.
Im Innenraum, ja.
Dann bist du komplett angeglichen an den Außenraum, weil da seien es nämlich
24,8. Hier ist es ein bisschen kühler gerade in der Meta-Ebene. So sieht es aus.
Das waren jetzt auch wichtige Informationen für euch. Hat euch bestimmt total interessiert.
Leute, wir sehen uns die Tage wieder und dann sagen wir bis dahin erstmal Tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.